news now reporter kristen drummond is
live in the arts district on maine near
charleston
with those preparations kristin
brian i'm outside of girl clothing and
as you can see here behind me
the windows have been boarded up here
there's a mural right now painted across
the plywood panels and
if we take a step inside you will see
that all the merchandise
has been removed from the store the
owner telling me
this is just a precaution just in case
if there's any
civil unrest or violence that may happen
tomorrow night
now crew put the boards up on saturday
it's the same plywood used earlier this
year to protect the property
when the states shut down all
non-essential businesses but
not everyone is taking this same
approach most managers or owners of
properties and the arts district tell me
they're not covering the windows and
it's not going to be business
as usual but different views as we count
down to election night
i'm pretty safe i feel pretty confident
that it won't get
to a volcano eruption it's not a matter
of being
paranoid it's a matter of taking matter
into your own hands and looking at it as
a strong individual and saying i'm going
to do whatever i can
to do what's best for myself and
my brand and my company
metro police plan to boost their
presence on election day the department
will open a deployment operations center
to monitor potential
safety threats and that's normally done
when major events like new year's eve
happen
there also be officers ready to
immediately respond to the voting
locations
and an additional 600 officers on
standby
to help the patrol division now back out
here at
girl clothing the owner tells me she
plans to keep the
wooden panels up through probably
november 14th
and that date because that's when she
plans to have an open house
this location still has not been open to
the public yet because
of the pandemic so she's hoping to
remove the boards
welcome everyone inside for that open
house in about a week and a half
reporting live in the arts district
kristen drummond 8 news now